[Music]
coming up i'll be showing you a stunning
vegetarian lunch and dinner
but first here's a more in-depth look at
the key ingredients you'll need for them
first for dinner i'm using risotto rice
risotto is a flagship classic in italian
cuisine but it's widely believed that
the spaniards introduced it to northern
italy back in the middle ages
there are three main types
arboreal carnaroli
and violoni
their ability to absorb liquid and
flavor whilst releasing lots of starch
is what makes risotto uniquely delicious
and anxious
a tasty creamy and inexpensive way to
satisfy lots of tummies without a morsel
of meat in sight now we're gonna make a
delicious beetroot risotto we need to
get the shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
no i haven't actually shallots please
into the pan for daddy
add a sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic
once you start cooking the risotto it's
really important
to have your stock
gently boiling away
if we're adding cold stock on top of the
rice all the time it just slows down the
process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of cooks at different temperatures
what stock is that in there dad because
that's a vegetable stock yeah because
you can't have different stocks if it's
more vegetarian can you
have chicken stock i made that mistake
once putting beef stock in the
vegetarian soup
no i didn't matilda are you sure i'm
positive i'm joking
fry off time how nice does that smell it
smells
delicious rice in that's a bit of a
different rice this is elboria rice it's
a perfect rice for risotto
now it's really important to sear
the rice if you were just to put the
stocking without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for daddy
it's just going to make a flawless no
flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
i'm adding red wine
followed by the first ladle of stock to
get things started now we're off
wow it's giving it a cloudy sort of look
[Music]
what's happening to the stock the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump
one of risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking there we
have to cook it all the way okay ready
for the next ladle i'm ready good girl
here we go ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes
and we're nursing it all the way
beetroots
peel them rub them a little bit of salt
and sugar yeah and a little bit of aged
balsamic vinegar in there roasted them
i'm gonna grate
my parmesan
how's that rice doing the rice is doing
good now that is exactly where we want
to be now look look at that nice glossy
textured rice so beetroot i need to put
two-thirds of the beetroot in there for
me saving one-third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
nice it's like it's snowing again and
then we're just gonna get some nice
butter in there
the butter gives the risotto a really
nice gloss
look at that beautiful
let that come down let it come down
first
all right get your spoon in there now
for daddy
beautifully there you go good
wonderful shake it risotto should be
like lava
it just
flows out and then the rest of the
beetroot on top
and then
finish
and some extra virgin olive oil
on top
you